there are enough people who hate me that
that's actually kind of an act of
Bravery to come out and say that you
like me I feel like there are a lot of a
lot of people who actively dislike me so
man that that makes me sad to to hear
you say that I I think you're great man
and and I love
you're I really love your music it is
like um my just
the best uh you know Just Energy it's
not like super like bummer it's not like
crazy it's just like well thanks groovy
now why would you say that a lot of
people just genuinely dislike you just
because of evidence
based on being alive
and yeah I mean I work under the
assumption that some people don't
dislike me but uh yeah over the years
people have made it pretty clear that
you know some people really don't like
me very much
um going way back you know a couple of
decades Eminem being the most famous
example of that that didn't help yeah I
don't know that I think that in the
whole Eminem thing I
I think that was an L for Eminem
honestly well because if you think about
the world of like
hip-hop kind of like gangster rap like
it's it's very like
tough
you know like two beef with Moby there's
no street cred in that even so the one
time he kind of published I have nothing
against Eminem I think he's really
talented I certainly
I almost don't have an opinion about him
but he attacked me at an MTV Music
Awards like 20 years ago
and the next day uh I was listening to
Howard Stern and Howard Stern said
exactly what you said it's like who
wants to pick on Moby you know it's like
picking on like the weak kid who doesn't
know how to tie his shoelaces like right
this is not but I think I think Eminem's
Mo at that point was just like okay I'm
gonna pick on anybody who's successful
you know what I mean just I don't know
about that yeah but the thing because it
was like Britney Spears in sync
Backstreet Boys all those people people
who couldn't fight back yeah yeah yeah
but like hating on you is like it's like
you're not malicious in anything that
you do and it's like somebody like like
you're an artist and so that's like
somebody not liking Picasso's artwork
and just [__] hating Picasso because
they don't like their artwork I mean
like why would somebody dislike you so
much for no reason I can't remember what
the specifics of the Eminem thing was
but but didn't have any reason yeah I
kind of provoked him
sure so if you remember in the late 90s
there was this culture of weird misogyny
and homophobia like all of a sudden like
rock bands Etc were like writing songs
that were weirdly misogynistic and
homophobic and I having been raised by
Progressive hippies I was a little
surprised by this and I spoke out about
this because Eminem had songs about
killing gay people and killing women and
putting them in the trunk of his car and
I was like maybe this is not setting the
best example for the 13 year olds
listening to Eminem and then
um he got upset that I criticized him
and this is where maybe the whole I'm
gonna
throw myself under the bus a little bit
I thought this was really funny
but he clearly did not is I was doing an
MTV interview and the journalist asked
me like why does Eminem have such an
issue with you and I said I don't know
maybe he's closeted and he just wants to
make out with me
so that might have been my equivalent of
like pouring kerosene on the fire sure
so
so in his case maybe he has a very good
reason to not like me but I thought I
was just being funny but clearly I'm not
have you have you ever ran into him
since or nope nothing nothing he's also
in our Cult of sobriety yeah I wouldn't
be surprised
to to hear that there was uh an area I
wouldn't even be surprised if it
happened and just didn't come up because
we sort of leave that stuff on the other
side but I didn't think there could be
an amends there probably from both we
could do a mutual amendment is it like a
reach around amends
um it's it's really pretty rare I think
that when you do come to somebody to
acknowledge that you were wrong I think
the majority of the time that person
meets you in the middle and acknowledges
their part too oh boy yeah I mean that
you know to shift from very
light-hearted and fun hopefully funny to
very Earnest like the ninth step which
is that the amends step oh my God it's
one of the most powerful things I've
ever done like reaching out to people
who I was convinced like they hated me
and I honestly made amends to them and
they started crying wow you know and
it's so
powerful and and transformation I don't
know if you ever if you had that
experience as well
I do and good news is Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude